do you feel like somebody who's taken
that path that is extremely the hard
path the long way right yeah do you feel
like when you see like artists talking
about their black ball do you feel like
that's a real thing
um
I feel like it is a real thing
but it's not you feel me I feel like
when artists say they black ball it's
about accountability [ __ ] you
blackballed yourself at the end of the
day you feel I'm saying it's about
certain things you've done or certain
things you may have said or ways you may
have done it but at the end of the day
you're not wrong for that right you're
not wrong for being yourself it's an
industry full of reasons why [ __ ]
Can't Be theyself right it's a fake ass
industry it's a [ __ ] industry it's
an industry full of [ __ ] that's afraid
to be they self so at the end of the day
when you feel like you blackballed you
may be but at the end of the day [ __ ]
even if you are I promise you it's
always late at the end of the tunnel
Real [ __ ] Gonna always win so if
you're a real [ __ ] just be yourself and
do the next best thing if I'm saying
like blackballing it is real is true but
at the end of the day but they can only
blackball you so much so much because
the internet's still there yeah the
internet is so when you try to build and
bet on yourself and do the next best
thing if I'm saying that's the that's
the thing that's why I don't believe in
a black ball because they internet is so
powerful it's so powerful and if the
internet can't blackball you if they
[ __ ] with you if the industry blackball
you and the internet [ __ ] with you
you're gonna still win NBA young that's
why young boys still winning NBA young
boy period you feel me people gotta [ __ ]
with you NBA youngboy is the most
anti-industry best of the most
anti-industry [ __ ] ever you from saying
you got to give a [ __ ] they they credit
yeah you know what I'm saying I saw yeah
I saw that's what I mean did you see
what Russ just said
pretty much was like you know
it's not as long as the internet is
alive and you have fans you have fans
you can't be friends it's impossible bro
you know what I'm saying so people have
to like you said people have to take
accountability take accountability and
just say all right look in the mirror
look in the mirror say all right but let
me build even if you want to apologize
on the internet let me just think about
myself right now 100 build this [ __ ]
back up organically from the mud because
if you will Hustler or a street [ __ ]
you know you're gonna go down to zero
get yourself back up you got to
understand that's the name of the game
don't take this [ __ ] personal [ __ ] when
you take a loss don't blame the labels
don't blame nobody in the mirror
I [ __ ] up yeah let me get this [ __ ]
right Point Blank period that's that's
just is what it is it's how humility is
missing man this is what it is yeah
accountability and humility two two
traits every grown man should have and I
know that and I understand that because
I built this [ __ ] from the ground yeah
and [ __ ] when [ __ ] was over here
betting on that they like I'm betting on
this yeah and then when that [ __ ] ain't
work now [ __ ] Back betting on me but
you wasn't betting on me then I was
betting on myself so you could never
blackball me I could never take it
personal I'm not gonna look at you like
oh you a [ __ ] [ __ ] you was [ __ ] with
him two years ago now you [ __ ] with
me all right bet appreciate you for
[ __ ] with me yeah I [ __ ] with you too
yeah that's where I'm at that's I don't
care about none of this [ __ ] Bro take
that [ __ ] personal bro